[Musique]
tous savent aujourd'hui maroni je vais
te faire découvrir un super dispositif
le fonds d aide aux jeunes un joli coup
de pouce pour de jeunes adultes
[Musique]
justement je suis en route pour
rencontrer tristan qui en a bénéficié il
va tout nous expliquer tu vas voir ok
bonne journée à toi
vous aussi le fond des deux jeunes ça
vous intéresse alors suivez-moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce jeune en situation de handicap a pu
bénéficier du fonds d aide aux jeunes
proposés par le département dans le
cadre d'une réinsertion professionnelle
avec ce soutien financier tristan a pu
suivre la formation qu'ils voulaient et
obtenir son diplôme au lama allez on va
tout de suite leur gendre
bonjour tristesse bonjour alors
concrètement à quoi tu as servi le fond
dette départementale aux jeunes le fonds
départemental d'aidé aux jeunes m'a
permis de financer un atelier
professionnel ont pas et transports en
commun et comment ce dispositif va aider
dans la vie sur mes projets
professionnels par rapport à ma
formation pendant mon ma demande de
permis et qu'est ce qui t'a plu dans ce
dispositif
j'ai aimé la ponctualité leur sérieux de
travail quand j'avais besoin d'eux ma is
it est tout le temps là qu'on écoute
mercier tristan hureaux merci
depuis 2005 le département grâce au f d
aj favorise l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle des jeunes de 18 à 25
ans en difficulté
et si nécessaire les ados faire face à
des besoins urgents
alors nous sommes ici à la cellule
d'insertion par l'innovation de saint
paul où nous pouvons rencontrer des
professionnels du département qui
mobilise le fond d'elle départementale
pour les jeunes alors concrètement qui
peut bénéficier de cette aide est bien
peuvent bénéficier du fonds
départemental de nos jeunes l'ofs d'âge
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans révolus non
scolarisés concrètement qu'est ce que le
doj
le village est une aide financière
ponctuelle qui permet d'aider les jeunes
dans le cadre de leur projet d'insertion
ou de répondre à des besoins urgents
précis reconnu suite à une évaluation
établie par un travailleur social du
département il permet notamment d'aider
les jeunes pour subvenir à des besoins
vitaux comme des dépenses alimentaires
des dépenses d'habillement d'équipement
en effet personnel mais aussi de prendre
en charge ces dépenses d'accès aux soins
comme la complémentaire santé solidaire
c'est à dire nexen une mutuelle les
frais de transport liés un projet
d'insertion peuvent aussi être prises en
charge en cas de guidage comme des frais
d'hébergement ou de maintien dans le
logement justement cette aide s'élève à
quel montant le montant moyen du village
et de 200 euros mais ce montant peut
être déplafonné jusqu'à 1500 euros en
fonction de la situation du jeune et sur
présentation de justificatifs et pour
qu'on voit en bénéficier il faut se
rendre à la maison départementale la
plus proche de son domicile
isabelle vous remercier alexandre
grâce à cet accompagnement du
département les jeunes profitent d'une
aide financière pour la réalisation de
leurs projets restants a été accompagné
par un conseiller tout au long des
démarches un suivi qui permet aux
bénéficiaires d'être informé le plus
rapidement possible sur l'avancée du
dossier
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur le fond des deux
jeunes n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes
les coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents rendez
vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux quant à moi je vous retrouve
très vite pour un nouvel épisode à
bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous allons
découvrir le dispositif apld et à
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
permet aux personnes âgées de 60 ans et
plus en perte d'autonomie nouvel ep fait
des aides et des services nécessaires à
l'accomplissement des actes essentiels
de la vie
[Musique]